mais d'abord donc l'europe emmanuel
macron en tête qui conforte l'ukraine
dans son soutien les principales
déclarations avec jonathan dépouillait
pas les marines qui en plein centre de
kiev c'est ici que le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky a reçu ses
homologues européens le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz l'italien mario
draghi mais aussi emmanuel macron tous
trois foulent le sol ukrainien pour la
première fois depuis le début de la
guerre une visite symbolique a sorti des
annonces concrètes notamment sur le plan
militaire il faut du matériel mais il le
faut vite c'est aussi pourquoi au delà
des douze césars d'ores et déjà livrés
conformément à vos demandes j'ai pris la
décision pour que dès les prochaines
semaines si césar additionnel puisse
l'être les européens ont surtout voulu
lancer un signal politique fort à
l'ukraine lui a octroyé immédiatement
son statut officiel de candidat à
l'union si le processus peut prendre des
années le président ukrainien se dit
prête à y travailler
nous sommes prêts à travailler pour que
notre état devienne membre à part
entière de l'union européenne les
ukrainiens ont déjà mérité le droit de
se mettre sur cette voie et d'obtenir le
statut de candidat arrivé en train ce
jeudi matin les dirigeants de l'ue eux
se sont aussi rendus sur le terrain
notamment à haïr pin ville martyre en
banlieue de kiev où la résistance
ukrainienne a repoussé moscou au début
de la guerre un héroïsme saluée par le
président de la république
la faune ville
héroïque puisque c'est ici que mais
entre autres que des et craignent les
ukrainiens ont arrêté l'armée russe qui
descendait sur kiev je pense que
représente l héroïsme mode
de l'armée mais aussi une
populations d'autres sujets stratégiques
ont aussi été abordés lors de ce
déplacement la poursuite de l'aide
humanitaire mais aussi la levée du
blocus russe sanctions les céréales en
mer noire
voilà notre premier débat est donc
consacrée aux conséquences diplomatiques
de cette
visite de quatre dirigeants européens en
ukraine je vous présente mes invités
rina dmitri chine bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes maître de conférences à l'institut
national des langues et civilisations
orientales responsable des études du
craignait j'accueille également patricia
allemonière bonsoir bienvenue patricia
grand reporter spécialiste des relations
internationales christian makarian
bonsoir bienvenue aux journalistes
spécialisés questions internationales
chroniqueur internationale au pur et
lætitia cru pas éditorialiste politique
bonsoir laetitia et bienvenue à vous
aussi irina dmitri chine quatre chefs
d'état et de gouvernement réunis autour
du président hélène ski bon le symbole
est fort qu'est ce que vous retenez des
annonces ou
parce que cette rencontre a parfaitement
répondu aux attentes ukrainienne et
c'est cela qui compte donc ça a balayé
toutes les polémiques toutes les
attentes tout les ou
mauvaise concordance en quelque sorte
entre les uns et les autres et donc
c'est annoncer le soutien je dirais sans
faille des ambitions ukrainienne
aujourd'hui a été hautement appréciée
donc je pense que c'est une très bonne
chose mais patricia allemonière c ces
quatre pays c'est pas notre finalement
la composition de ceux de ce groupe est
ce que vous diriez que c'est une sorte
de de condensé de l'europe 2
d'aujourd'hui ou qu'on a échappé peu à
l'heure d'hiver j'irai pour l'échappée
belle parce que je crois que dans la
préparation au début de cette de cette
rencontre de cette visite là l'idée
était de prendre l'allemagne l'italie et
la france et que les trois en somme la
vieille europe celle dont celle qu'a
créé l'europe et celle qui est aussi
adapté la plus modérée la moins enclins
à soutenir à fond si j'osais
et bien l'ukraine d'ailleurs on voit que
c'est dans ces pays d'après les
dernières études et les sondages où les
gens sont le moins allants pour la
guerre le moins allants pour soutenir
effectivement l'ukraine est bien là au
dernier moment où on a sauvé les meubles
en quelque sorte on a invité le
président ukrainien et dont le président
aura reçu les excuses et moi room est
donc laissée vide dans ce cas là c'est
l'europe l'europe de l'ouest plus
l'europe de l'est celle qui a vécu dans
ses chairs finalement
la présence de l'armée soviétique et
tout ce que ça pouvait entraîner donc
dans ce cas là on a les deux europe et
donc on a vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine
quelque chose de très important qui
démontre et l'europe restent unis
christian makarian c'est quoi pour vous
le l'annoncent la plus importante y en a
eu il y en a eu plusieurs notamment de
la part de d'émané le maquereau y aller
les canons caesar supplémentaires je le
disais en titi à l'adhésion là le
processus d'adhésion à l'union va y
évidemment il consacré un chapitre il ya
une histoire de laboratoires mobiles d'
analyses adn il ya aussi un appel lancé
au président poutine sur le le les
exportations de céréales débloquer
odessa qu'est ce que vous retenez vous
voilà je crois que tout ce que vous
voulez d'énumérer est important le plus
important c'est l'ouverture immédiate du
statut de candidat à l'union européenne
candidat immédiat c'est le terme
immédiat employés parce que ça contient
tout le reste c'est à dire que à partir
de là quand ça sera consacré le 23 juin
donc là dans quelques jours au conseil
européen l'udc si la russie attend
encore à l'ukraine
ça sera
une atteinte à un pays candidat à
l'union ça va quand même changé le degré
de gravité de tout cela il faut bien y
réfléchir du point de vue occidental à
ça suppose un investissement beaucoup
plus profond et un engagement
plus risqués c'était c'est évident mais
tout est important le fait d'aller à
irbine par exemple se lie à mon avis
comme une grande victoire craignent
elles parce que qu'est ce qu'a démontré
l'ukraine quelque chose de fondamental
sur le plan militaire c'est que partout
où l'ukraine avait a été les forces
russes les forces russes s'étaient
retirés et parfois même piteusement donc
sa sellerie cuir in c'est un symbole de
la cétose la capacité de résistance sein
du peuple et de l'armée ukrainienne
voilà du fed a fait la démonstration du
fait que aider l'ukraine militairement
cette le seul moyen d'arrêter
l'avancée de la russie et là où elle
avance c'est à dire dans le donbass pas
à pas mais tout de même elle avance
c'est parce que justement le cren n'a
pas de moyens militaires suffisants d'où
l'apport de cissé à supplémentaires
c'est pas par hasard d'artillerie or
c'est avec l'artillerie que les russes
écrase la ville par exemple de ces vélos
donetsk donc il n'ya vraiment énormément
de chose en soi ya j'ai pu enfin il faut
pas l'oublier a qu'à l'envers du décor
chacun des présidents présents sauf le
roumain avait quand même un petit
contentieux à effacer oui avec quelques
malentendus elle avéo à dire ça
diplomatiquement les allemands étaient
quand même très engagé du côté de la
russie ils ont pas envoyé d'armement
sérieux à part des jumelles des postes
radio et instruments de mesure
franchement il était très en dessous de
la main donc il a fallu rattraper ça
c'était une grosse session de rattrapage
sous les manuels macro masse et la
fameuse phrase il ne faut pas émis
humilié la russie fortement déplu en
ukraine il a fallu qu'une police les
angles qu'il rabote tout ça et qu'ils
mettent un peu de polish ça a beaucoup
plus de lure maintenant un quant aux
italiens d'une part
l'extrême droite dont luigi di maio le
ministre des affaires étrangères italien
actuel est toujours issue était archi
pro-russe et pro poutine même admiratif
de poutine il fallait le faire oublier
et puis et puis l'italie est très
dépendante sur le plan énergétique
notamment gaziers de la russie donc elle
a été très réservée au début donc
finalement les trois pays fondateurs de
l'union européenne
france allemagne italie se sont
retrouvés dans une nécessité de
redresser leur image et je crois que
l'opération est réussie alors irina
dmitri chine sur sur les l'armement
parce qu'évidemment on a bien compris et
c'est quelque chose que les dirigeants
ukrainiens
martel à chaque intervention avec des
homologues internationaux donc il ya
cette annonce des manuels macron juste
pour être bien précis si canon caesar
supplémentaires on avait déjà livré ou
promis 12 ça fait 18 ans en a 76 en
france donc c'est quand même un effort
important bien sûr il est ressenti comme
tel
on n'a jamais assez parce que les
besoins sont extrêmement importants dont
il parle quand même en termes de
capacité de dar thierry de le ratio d'un
an contre 10 donc donc même les quelques
canons supplémentaires mais qui s'ajoute
à tout le reste qui est livrée par
d'autres on espère par les allemands par
les américains par les britanniques donc
donc tout cela finira par faire inverser
les choses et l'ukraine est parfaitement
consciente aussi ceux qui vont au fond
des choses que l'europe a aussi un
déficit de n'a pas non plus les
capacités des pays qu'on peut investir
sur leur armement cela fait des
décennies c'est sûr donc donc on est
conscient qu'il ya aussi d'aider entre
les demandes et les besoins et la
capacité réelle des pays occidentaux de
livres et qu'il ya aussi des choses à
des pressions des et des capacités
nationales dont il faut tenir compte
mail annonce vient à point nommé et donc
ça ajoute a donc tout à fait d'accord
que l'essentiel c'était quand même le
message politique mais les armes
arrivent petit à petit donc c'est ça qui
compte emmanuel macron vous le savez
avait repoussé plusieurs fois son voyage
en or en ukraine sous prétexte qu'il
irait en temps voulu en temps utile est
ce que le déplacement était utile selon
vous laetitia c'est intéressant de vous
entendre avant moi puisque j'ai dû
répondre à cette question pour l écrire
un monde et d'un d'entendre les experts
et finalement j'ai retenu la même chose
c'est-à-dire que utile dans les faits
militaires dans les bons tout ce qu'il
apporte pas vraiment puisqu'il emmanuel
macron avait promis de venir pour
infléchir le cours de la guerre en temps
voulu donc il y avait vraiment une
promesse d'efficacité
sur du long terme thomas infléchir le
cours de la guerre bon là
vraisemblablement
ça va pas être un tournant majeur dans
cette guerre en ukraine mais vous avez
raison et rina question les mots les
mots son voile a été vraiment ce
capitaux dans cette en se pendant dans
cette visite parce que les ukrainiens
avaient besoin de réassurance ou saab il
avait inventé ce mot mac rooney qui veut
dire que on s'inquiète d'une situation
il dit haut et fort et puis finalement
on ne fait rien fait pas grand chose
voilà donc emmanuel macron bien sûr oui
les italiens les allemands mais emmanuel
macron au premier plan devait démontrer
en fait le soutien de la france et de
l'europe à l'ukraine et c'est pour ça
c'est vrai qu'il a utilisé des mots très
forts les mots dans le début de sa prise
de parole à la conférence de presse sont
très claires simples directs il dit il
répète qu'il salue l'héroïsme des
ukrainiens ça il l'avait déjà dit le
matin à aire pinins mais il dit aussi
qu'il sera là et que l'europe sort là
pour soutenir de façon unilatérale
aujourd'hui mais aussi demain les
ukrainiens contre le choix injustifiée
et injustifiable d'une guerre qui sert à
asservir un peuple libre et que les
européens
n'accepteront jamais ils ont un sens ces
mots ils sont encore une fois simple
compréhensible par tous il a insisté sur
la fraternité des européens et il était
urgent de le dire à volodimir et l'ins
kiki c'est vrai avec on va commencer à
nourrir un ressentiment vis-à-vis du
chef de l'état français on le voit sur
les images je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
vu ce qui ne regarde quasiment jamais
emmanuel macron le fait un monde donner
parce qu il est interpellé donc il est
un peu forcé de regarder de bié
furtivement le chef de l'état français
mais on sent qu'il ya une tension entre
les deux hommes alors c'est vrai moi
j'aurais dit que côté ukrainien il
l'aurait certainement un peu de
déception encore une fois sur ce cours
de la guerre mais finalement on voit que
le message diplomatique
les mots les symboles sont les plus
fortes patricia allemonière et c est ce
que finalement dire on va infléchir le
je n'irai que quand on pourra infléchir
le cours de la guerre s'était pas
présenté quoi
ça pouvait pas être emmanuel macron même
accompagné d'autres d'autres différends
et dirigeants européens qui allait faire
basculer le cours de la guerre d'autant
que l'on connaît vadimir poutine on a
appris à le connaître fil des années
c'est quelqu'un qui aime le rapport de
forces est donc finalement celui qui
veut discuter avec lui il n'a pas
forcément
l'estiment nécessaire qu'on pourrait
penser alors je pense qu emmanuel macron
a évolué dans sa perception c'est assez
sensibles c'est à dire qu'au départ je
pense qu'il voulait faire de la réelle
politique ce qu'on appelle être
pragmatique et dire bon bah voilà on
sortira un jour de la guerre et le jour
où on sortira de la guerre mais il
faudra bien discuter si ce n'est qu un
v8 sur le principe c'est bon mais
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que la
guerre ça va durer probablement et que
si on sations s'inscrit dans ce temps
long de la guerre à laquelle les
opinions publiques je le dis bien ne
sont pas préparés les gens ne sont pas
prêts et on le voit dans les études à
faire des efforts soutenus pendant
longtemps pour l'ukraine ils sont bien
prêts à en faire tout de suite donc ces
trois chefs d'état sont obligés quand
même aussi de tenir compte de leur
opinion publique alors justement je
viens d'être à jamais ma un élément
intéressant apporter à notre débat qui
va dans votre sens et cette enquête du
conseil européen des relations
étrangères
sondages en quelque sorte auprès de 8000
citoyens européens dans 10 pays avec
cette question comment résoudre le
conflit en ukraine on voit que alors
cepsum globale pour tous les européens
interrogés 35% sont pour une paix rapide
au prix de concessions territoriales
évidemment c'est ça qui est important
dans la question en france c'est 41 %
c'est un peu plus élevée et
22% des personnes interrogées européen
tout compris sont pour que la russie se
retirer la france et 20% qui sur ma
carrière on met les ovins les chefs
d'état qu'était à kiev aujourd'hui et
tous les chefs d'état européens
évidemment c'est une lapalissade que je
vais dire mais ils doivent tenir compte
de leur opinion publique donc ce risque
de quoi de lassitude un peu des opinions
face à une guerre qui dure de plus en
plus longtemps quand comment vous
l'analysez vous eh bien il me semble
qu'il s'est passé quelque chose encore
une fois d'importants haïr pin on a vu
sur les ai vu des visages des trois jeux
d'état et même du quatrième même du
président et ioannis le président
roumain on a vu énormément d'émotion
parce que à force de parler d' équilibre
des forces de la loi du plus fort de
diplomatie de négociations on oublie que
la guerre ça consiste à tuer des enfants
des femmes des personnes âgées des
innocents et puis des hommes entre eux
qui sont enrôlés sous l'uniforme c'est
une horreur et un cortège d'horreurs et
si vous voulez ma monnaie les gens
prennent leur avis sur leur m en
conscience la wii il était un peu
désincarnées l'état
c'est était en deçà de l'opinion
publique française aux stades
émotionnels
parce que regarder on n'a pas beaucoup
mais beaucoup de français ont hébergé
des ukrainiens continue d'ailleurs de le
faire et eu un mouvement de solidarité
énorme et profond et on a découvert une
spontanéité de toute l'europe
occidentale pour accueillir les réfugiés
eux craignent c'est un sujet dont on
parle très peu par rapport à d'autres
types de réfugiés c'est pas tout à fait
innocent donc ce team de mouvements
spontanés dans l'opinion publique existe
et les dirigeants ont laissé
l'impression qu'ils étaient treize ans
en réserve en arrière de tout cela parce
que ils ont peur des conséquences
militaires globales que ça peut
entraîner mais c'est pas le cas des
américains c'est pas le cas des pays
d'europe de l'est donc quelque part les
états unis d'un côté très engagé contre
la russie l'europe de l'est très
déterminée contre la russie a fait que
l'europe occidentale est apparu trop sur
la réserve et pour tout dire isolé isolé
dans le camp occidental est isolé même à
l'intérieur de la famille européenne
donc il a fallu lever tout cela
maintenant à kiev will et les
britanniques sont complètement
différents le peuple britannique a
l'impression par rapport à ces ce qui se
passe en ukraine qui rejouent la seconde
guerre mondiale ils ont l'impression
qu'ils sont face à un éclair et boris
johnson du joue là dessus mais c'est pas
les avis de ben johnson qui compte pour
les britanniques c'est ce que le et des
britanniques pensent à l'intérieur
d'eux-mêmes ils sont ils ont un rapport
à cette guerre qui est très éloigné de
celui des pays de l'europe de l'ouest
mais pour aller dans le même sens que ce
que vous dites comme par hasard c'est le
pays qui est sortie de l'europe qui est
un pays occidental qui est sortie de
l'europe et le plus engagé aux côtés de
l'ukraine donc ça accentue ce que
j'essayais de dire en valeur ses yeux le
fait que les pays d'europe de l'ouest
apparaissent trop timorés dans cette
affaire là irina dmitri si nous autres
éléments de ce sondage 42% des des
européens interrogés un rappel 8000
personnes 10 pays et sim 42% estiment
que leur pays en fait trop envers
l'ukraine au détriment des problèmes
intérieurs donc c'est comment vouliez
intervenir là dans cette partie du débat
voilà c'est quand même intéressant de
voir les opinions publiques peut-être
petit à petit ça dépend des pays c'est
très disparaître en train d'évoluer je
pense que c'est moins liés à la guerre
ce qui se passe là-bas pour conséquence
récentes sur le pouvoir d'achat
exactement ce que sur économique qui
commence à inquiéter et puisqu'on fait
le lien avec ce qui se passe là bas on
se dit si on termine cette guerre le
plus vite possible peut-être on évitera
les conséquences waller une ses romans
douloureuse et c'est là où les hommes
politiques et les médias ou un rôle
pédagogique à faire d'expliquer que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on va arrêter
maintenant la guerre à tout prix que ses
conséquences vont être amoindrie qu'il
n'ya pas de paix sans justice et que vos
l'accident s'il ya un pays se lance dans
sa chambre ce genre d'agression il est
important pour tous de l'arrêter pour
éviter les conséquences du violent plus
important il ya non seulement par
exemple à expliquer peut-être aux
populations occidentales parce qu'on se
pose tous la question si le donbass par
exemple 2 milliard us qu'est ce que ça
change
parce que l'on comprend que pour les
ukrainiens et bien évidemment les
violations mais ça l'est du pays et
fondamentale qui met d'accord avec les
desserts que ça rejoint là le premier
livre que je n'ai une paix rapide au
prix de concessions territoriales on va
entendre cette petite musique bombe
après tout je dis pas que c'est c'est
juste mais après tout l'ukraine peut
peut se lâcher le dombass et puis comme
ça la guerre est finie le premier ce
n'est pas que de ma ceinture et vu tout
le sud de l'ukraine ni les prix c'est
quand 25% aussi des terres arables qui
sont qui sont ces gens qui est venue
elle m'a quoi rappeler qu'il fallait
restaurer l'ukraine dans ses frontières
antérieures à la guerre donc écrit mais
y compris donc on ira 2014 inclus non
seulement le dôme masse bellac louis
donc c'est un roger de l'annexion de la
crimée en mars 2014 par la russie est un
rejet total de ce qui a été fait dans le
dos de base et en plus il ya des
ententes internationales par exemple les
fameux mémorandum de budapest qui ont
proclamé le caractère intangible co
signée par la russie de l'époque le
caractère intangible des frontière
ukrainienne donc quelque part les
européens et là les américains sont
dedans aussi n'ont pas tenu parole sur
le respect certaine manière c'est en
2014 que le problème se pose et c'est là
qu'il fallait réagir puis la parole
officielle et c'est vrai qu emmanuel
macron ne peut pas dire en tant que chef
d'état français il ne peut c'est
impossible d'entendre ça de dire le
donbass après tout s'il devient russie
n'est pas grave c'est pas possible je
parle des opinions publiques
occidentales notamment françaises pour
qui effectivement une partie du
territoire ukrainien d'un avenant russes
n'auraient pas de conséquence directe
par exemple et donc il y aurait moins de
solidarité vis-à-vis du crème vous
comprenez cela
besoin de la solidarité les ukrainiens
répondait l'alsace et la lorraine ou à
leurs données
publiques ont pété va doit porter non
pas seulement sur la restitution des
territoires mais sur le statut des
territoires il ya eu un moment
il ya à peu près un mois et demi ou le
ministre affaires étrangères du mythe
recouler bas a dit nous sommes
absolument pas disposé à parler des
frontières à remettre en cause des
frontières de l'ukraine qui sont pour
nous intangibles en revanche on peut
parler du statut d'une basse alors
l'issue elle est peut-être là elle est
peut-être là c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
étaient contenues dans les accords de
minsk au départ et qui n'a pas été
respecté il faut être honnête par aucune
des deux parties ni par la russie ni par
l'ukraine donc niveau de finition du
matin on en est sans doute très loin
mais si on essaye patricia allemonière
d'imaginer des négociations elles
porteront sur quoi
porteront bien sûr ni des questions
territoriales sur des négociations il
faut les imaginer à partir du moment où
la guerre s'arrête c'est à dire où en
seront les combattants aujourd'hui si
nous admettons le front devait se mettre
sur le dôme basse je ne vois pas
pourquoi les russes
accepterait de reculer et on le voit
très bien quand il ya eu des
négociations et des accords en quelque
sorte en 2015 il y a eu une ligne de
partage et cette ligne de partage tout
le monde accepte et on a signé des tas
de papiers avec un
calendrier un processus des élections à
mettre en place après des des armes à
remettre à des tas de choses
merveilleuses et en fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé le texte a été signé les
chancelleries occidentales sont rentrées
chez elles en deux temps en temps
effectivement essayant de réanimer ce
processus et puis la plupart du temps ça
arrange et la russie puisque la range
ainsi qu'est ce qu'elle a fait est là
elle est repartie c'est à dire que si
aujourd'hui on signe et c'est la crainte
de tout le monde d accord on pensa que
ça repartira comme c'est reparti après
la crimée et comme c'est reparti après
le débat c'est la raison pour laquelle à
mon humble avis la pacification du dawn
base aux mêmes de la crimée est hélas ça
complique énormément le sujet totalement
dépendante d'un changement majeur à
moscou question est donc ça dépend
complètement ce que vladimir poutine et
monsieur lavrov sont allés trop loin
dans les déclarations qu'ils ont faites
pour eux mêmes se déjuger ça va être
très difficile alors on va on va parler
maintenant du de serre on l'évoqué
rapidement mais de cette procédure
d'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne et on va commencer tient pas
un une réaction qui nous ramène à la
politique française c'est celle de
marine le pen pour elle c'est tout à
fait clair elle ne veut pas de l'ukraine
dans l'union européenne
l'ukraine ne correspond à aucune des
conditions qui sont exigées par l'union
européenne pour pouvoir devenir adhérent
donc moi j'y suis je suis opposé mais
comme je suis opposé à tout
élargissement par ailleurs oui donc ce
n'est pas spécifique pour l'ukraine je
crois qu'il faut clairement dire à
l'ukraine que ça ne d'ailleurs nous ne
préjuge pas du soutien qui peut lui être
apportée par les pays de l'union
européenne mais je pense qu'il faut
clairement lui dire qu' elle ne remplit
pas les conditions pour aujourd'hui être
adhérentes de l'union européenne alors
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire je
commençais vous patricia allemonière
elle et elle est contre l'élargissement
mais moi ce qui m'inquiète effectivement
quand on parle d'élargissement comme ça
et je serais bref pour laisser là tout
le monde s'est exprimé c'est que c'est
un sentiment qui est un peu partagé en
europe c'est à dire que les gens ne sont
pas
grandi
c'est pour ça qu emmanuel macron
souvenez vous au mois de mai avait
proposé cette espèce de chose impossible
de communauté politique européenne
l'idée mis sur la table par françois
mitterrand dans les années 80 je crois
90 qui était morte née
emmanuel macron l'avait ressorti ça
aussi c'est mort né puisque maintenant
on parle d' adhésion immédiate mais
c'est bien qu'il ya bien un substrat en
europe des diolas attendait encore
s'ouvrir savez c'est l'ouvrier polonais
quoi qu'il arrive être déjà ils vont
venir qui vont venir qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont venir faire chez nous est-ce qu'ils
sont bien prêts est ce qu a pas trop de
corruption qui sont ces où on les aime
bien quand ils souffrent on est prêt les
défendre mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire une partie de l'opinion
certainement qui réagit comme ça à
christian makarian wiki favorable qui
généreuse évidemment sais c'est que
c'est hétérogènes par définition
christian makarian s'avoue boubou en
entendant marine le pen vous qu'est-ce
que vous êtes discours les fonctions un
an change vraiment pas une équipe qui
gagne j'ose dire elle était pro russe
donc il lui est difficile d'aimer
maintenant l'ukraine mon point de
l'admettre dans l'union européenne mais
elle oublie un détail c'est que quand
eric zemmour a protesté contre les et
les réfugiés l'ukrainien ça lui a coûté
très cher choplin électorale parce que
le peuple français est beaucoup plus
accueillant que l'extrême droite ne le
pense et deuxièmement deuxième pardon
des élections présidentielles oui et 2e
manon qu'on revient aux fondamentaux
donc chasser le chasser le naturel il
revient au galop et deuxièmement reste
extrêmement savoureux entendant marine
le pen défendre l'union européenne
aujourd'hui c'est absolument délicieux
ça nécessite quand même un coup de
chapeau et parle pas comme ça hors sol
marine le pen est bien sûr qu'elle
entend ces gens vous avez dit qu'ils
sont un peu réfractaires est certaine
frénésie
une fracture entre l'opinion publique
française notamment on va parler que
d'elle et l'imaginaire collectif
européen va l'imaginaire collectif oran
père défendue par les élites n'est pas
du tout celui des français et ça depuis
2005 vous savez bien le non au
référendum sur l'europe il ya une
cassure et aucun politique n'a réussi à
retirer le lien donc marine le pen elle
surf sur cette fracture la nécessité
d'expliquer exactement d'où l'importance
pour les politiques d'expliquer c'est ce
qu'on essaye aussi que vers nous avec
nous dans notre rôle de médiateur irina
dmitri chine les mots on s'appuie sur ce
qui a été annoncé cet après midi à kiev
éléments
candidature immédiate c'est ça qui est
important alors c'est pas l'adhésion
immédiate c'est la candidature avait
dire que ça prendra au bas mot 15 en dix
ans et donc oui voilà on ne sait pas
comment les choses bien
j'aime rapide serait 15 ans mais très
rapide et donc on est con mais ça veut
dire un habitant dans ces subsides ans
dans une semaine le le principe de la
procédure de l'ouverture la procédure
sera actée par les parler du compte à ce
stade c'est qu'on dise à rennes mais
pourquoi parce que pardon nous
interrompt vos limites en ce qu'ils
savaient qu'ils ne pouvaient pas obtenir
plus que ça d'une certaine façon qu'il
avait intégré cette idée parfaitement
conscient et les ukrainiens n'avais pas
d'attentes
donc qu'il n'était pas réaliste ce qui
ce qui compte et c'est cette valeur de
symbole de dire vous êtes un des nôtres
voilà c'est ce qui a été dit ici et je
rebondis sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure parce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre que vous nous dites ça change
la donne vis-à-vis de la russie
l'ukraine sera pas membre de l'union
européenne on va pas on ne va pas se
retrouver à être obligé défendre
l'ukraine sur son sol parce qu elle est
dans la procédure d'adhésion voyez avait
même précisé
d'abord il ya un deuil est toute une
série de dossiers préalable la serbie le
monténégro la macédoine du nord et puis
on a fait - nîmes l'albanie le kosovo
qui sont dans la salle d'attenté qui
sont dans la salle d'attenté avec
lesquels on a beaucoup avancé par
exemple les dernières élections que l'ue
en serbie il n'y a pas vraiment pas si
longtemps on était très importante parce
que le vainqueur est quand même
pro-européen et l'a proclamé sans désir
d'entrer dans l'union européenne au il
ya toute une mécanique qui a d'ailleurs
contribué à ralentir les propos de
emmanuel macron enfin verdure parce
qu'ils pensaient qu'il avait fait des
promesses déjà au pays balkaniques et
qu'il fallait pas non plus blessé les
balkanique en faisant passer l'ukraine
devant c'est ça on en revient au dessus
de la pile voilà c'est très compliqué
donc donc il faut procéder par ordre
mais d'abord c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour l'union européenne qu'elle
soit conçue comme une garantie mais ces
pays de l'ex union soviétique ont
observé quelque chose d'essentiel c'est
les trois pays baltes les pays baltes en
adhérant à l'union européenne se sont
trouvés auto protéger sert dix
appartiennent aussi à l'otan mais c'est
pas par hasard que certains d'entre eux
enfin tous pour tout dire maintenant ont
adopté aussi lauro ils sont dans
l'euroland or je vois pas tellement le
rapport entre l'euro et
ces pays bas et bien si l'eau est conçu
comme un moyen aussi d'accroître
d'intensifier de densifier le lien avec
l'europe il qui sert de protection et ça
c'est de nature si vous voulez a quand
même envoyé un message très clair et
très nette aux russes et enfin dernier
point emmanuel macron était à mon avis
d'autant plus heureux d'être aujourd'hui
peut-être à kiev avec les allemands les
italiens et les roumains pour faire
bonne mesure et mettre une portion de
rue d'europe de l'est dans l'ensemble ou
d'europe centrale il était d'autant plus
heureux parce que il a à convaincre et
ça en france on y accorde aucune
importance des pays encore drôlement
réticents par exemple le danemark la
hongrie ou les pays bas si proche de
nous qui ne sont pas favorables à
l'entrée de l'ukraine pour des raisons
alors là qui sont normatives et qui
tiennent à
l'unanimité oui une audition doit être
prise à l'unanimité sa prison car elle
est limitée de 27 pays donc emmanuel
macron en allant à kiev fait d'une
pierre plusieurs coups il ils essaient
aussi de montrer que au pays parce que
il n'est pas que président français il
est président du conseil de l'union
européenne pour encore une quinzaine de
jours il essaie de démontrer au danemark
aux pays-bas par exemple vous voyez bien
que la charge émotionnelle est énorme
vous voyez bien qu'on ne peut pas nous
opposer à ça au motif que parce que
c'est ça la met la motivation le le
refus néerlandais et danois prix que à
l'entrée de l'ukraine c'est l'état de
droit et oui il craignait pas en
situation état de droit non car elle n'a
pas les normes en matière de justice
d'impartialité elle n'a pas les normes
surtout en matière de lutte contre la
corruption
qui en connaît un rayon sur ce sujet
honnêtement donc ça n'enlève rien à son
héroïsme par ailleurs donc il ya quand
même des problèmes il faut pas le nier
mais c'est la raison pour laquelle ça va
prendre un certain temps mais sur le
plan politique il fallait prendre une
décision et celle qui consiste à ou
immédiatement l'acte de candidature de
l'ukraine à mon avis est une bonne
décision patricia allemonière jettera
pays à une triste chose très importante
c'est que adhérer on peut pas adhérer en
étant occupés à un quart du territoire
donc il va déjà falloir régler cette
question sur un plan du solde en quelque
sorte l'ukraine à 25 % de son territoire
qui échappe au gouvernement ukrainien
donc on peut on peut pas faire une
adhésion de 75 % du territoire alors le
processus effectivement va se mettre en
marche vous savez cas on peut faire en
plus des des signes en en complexifiant
un peu le processus et en donnant des
garanties des garanties militaires des
garanties
il ya des choses qui vont se faire parce
que là on n'est pas du tout dans la
situation des pays des balkans des ans
en situation d'une adhésion immédiate
d'un pays en état de guerre mais ça ne
s'est jamais produit en cours les pays
sortait des dictatures les pays sortait
du bloc soviétique mais n'était pas en
guerre et puis si on accepte le cren il
va falloir accepter la moldavie et là je
me sens pas en guerre tout ce serait
compliqué c'est là encore moins de
critères
et elle est occupée en partie aussi par
la réussite il ya une dernière question
dans les trente ans de l'aspirine à la
question de la reconstruction ça a été
aussi abordé cet après-midi lors lors de
ce sommet et c'est ça qui est paradoxal
c'est à dire que c'est la guerre il faut
se défendre et en même temps qu'on
commençait diplomatiquement à réfléchir
à d'éventuelles négociations est ce que
l'un diplomatique peut être rompu ou pas
et puis surtout à préparer la
reconstruction donc c'est quoi céder pas
encore des contrats qui se joue mais
c'est sait évaluer ce que de vaud à être
l'effort commun c'est ça oui mais les
contrats vont revenir très vite il ya
les chinois qui ont dit qu'ils étaient
intéressés sans doute d'autres villes
d'autres pays à part du mans où il ya
des gens qui vont venir les turcs
exactement bâtiments ou les font venir
je pense qu'il y aura il y aura d une
concurrence en quelque sorte jeu et
ensuite les ukrainiens le président qui
avait lancé cette idée de sorte de
patronage de certains pays sur certaines
villes sur certaines zones et cnra et
donc il ya déjà des cabinets
d'architectes et pays qui sont prêtes à
faire une vitrine d'une ville une
vitrine de lors de leur pays donc je
pense que ça peut aller vite ça
permettra aussi de faire revenir les
réfugiés
c'est en fait ça peut être vraiment
gagnant gagnant c'est très con struction
ce retour c'est une façon pour le cren
aussi de panser les plaies de surmonter
ce traumatisme donc tout le monde va
devrait devrait y mettre du sien il ya
un autre aspect dont on n'a pas parlé
qui peut-être été moins visible c'est
cette visite dans cette ville
effectivement elle est tout le monde
avait les visages est extrêmement marqué
mais il ya le travail donc destiné au
futur tribunal à lenquête et donc le
laboratoire la présence des gendarmes
français donc tout ce travail de fourmi
va porter ses fruits à terme et il va
aussi jouer pour donc là que la justice
soit faite ce qui s'est passé en ukraine
alors vous parliez des réfugiés
justement on leur conseille vous savez à
chaque fois qu'on a un débat sur le cren
un flash info et cette âme traduit qui
peut nous rejoindre tout de suite
herrina va assurer la la traduction
bonsoir tam bien bienvenue au comment ce
journal de l'ukraine avec le salon
viva tech qui se tient en ce moment à
paris et oui le plus grand salon
européen dédié à l'attak a ouvert ses
portes mercredi 2000 exposants et parmi
eux 14 start-up ukrainienne dont will
keep un système de sécurité invisible
pour protéger les vélos de vol ou encore
moss kiters protection écologique et
innovante contre les moustiques
nabil chiffres puisqu'ils saloon presley
sur
huit essais sur jasmin qu'il souhaitait
quelques titres notamment
you keep n'avait de ma système abo spa
qui a que ça qui cherche pas de l'esc
redire avons inscrits pour riches n'est
pas une matinée marquée ce titre comme
arrive parmi les têtes d'affiché de
cette édition noter les venus des 26
gueule le cofondateur et cie au de
snapshot ou encore jimmy wales qui est
lui le cofondateur de wikipedia le salon
se tient porte de versailles jusqu'à
samedi certains exposants qui sauvent
pascua piqueras seulement au tchèque
ivan hasek et la sfi la terrasse nachat
attaquant jimmy wales wikipedia
salle on dit qu'elle serait d'aller à
porte de versailles ont connu on
continue avec cette pétition qui
cartonne sur internet bientôt trente
mille signatures pour cette pétition
lancée sur challenge point org qui veut
loger des réfugiés ukrainien dans le
super yacht à mort et véro propriété de
l'oligarque russe igor setchine
actuellement gelée dans le port de la
ciotat oui cet été 6 pi depuis ce n'est
qu'il est peut-être ce nas haïti chain
scrap cowes y'a qu'à propos n'est pas
souhaitée aux créanciers bixente
superyacht à mon réveil je tenais je
précise que mon évolution
gaza strip nattes pagnes ou pour tous la
ciotat l'auteur de la pétition philippe
bonneau veut prendre exemple sur la
convention signée pour le méditerranée
ferry a marre et lui à marseille qui
était devenu l'un des plus grands
centres d'accueil du territoire français
pendant deux mois mission qui s'est
achevée vendredi dernier à philippe
bonneau
ouvre des possibilités
de
france et enfin l'unesco lance
au grain pour soutenir les artistes
ukrainiens objectif que ces artistes
puissent poursuivre leurs activités de
création malgré la guerre et que la
population continue d'avoir accès à la
culture face à cette situation l'unesco
lance un programme pilote en partenariat
avec l' ong ukrainienne musée d'art
contemporain moca younès que ça
pousserait programmons à pitre en coco
ainsi médecine mais tu as deux autres
crises qui mettent sans perdre au jour
d'autres vertus diane jardine avis nous
attaquent aux de second degré in some
produkt et matt dostum de culture
protéger
mon cas ce programme déjà doté par
l'unesco de 100 mille dollars va prendre
la forme de subventions versées aux
artistes l'accent sera mis sur les
projets qui contribuent à forger la
résilience des populations confrontées
au traumatisme de la guerre
ce programme avait carrément la ville
unesco staut et sèche de vote mais
finances au titre en commission au sabre
et votre commentaire
merci merci reina pour cette traduction
voilà c'est la fin de ce premier débat